And then we train the model.
Empire
and then we
go model dot train.
So this is going to learn from the first.
safety
thousand images
but then to evaluate
this model to see if it's overfitting or not. We'll use the
test data set if we look at the metric after training.
And if it's a very high score, it's very unlikely to
be 100% But if it's very high.
It could be overfitting. Well, the only way
for us to know if it is overfitting is to get to the test data set.
But if it's poor even from the start even from
the 20% then that's on their fitting so we don't
even need to proceed to the test test it is
that
So yes, if it's perfect 100% something might be.
Something might be off because it's very unlikely
for you to get a hundred percent accuracy.
Okay, then what am I looking for? Yes training images.
the train labels which here correspond to the class of the
picture
and which
Data set. We're going to use for validating.
validation
So for validation, we're going to use the test data
set.
So I'm going to go test images.
to pull test images
test
that would be yes.
I'm gonna run this.
And it's losses dot losses.
And then the other mistake is the epochs number
of epochs.
a box
epox refers to the number of times you're going to feed this data through
the network.
For larger models you want
to be careful with this? Because if you set a high number of epochs while
that may lead to higher accuracy, it can
take a long time for it to
terminate
so that that particular cell terminate.
so that is why sometimes may want to upgrade your
environment in colab you can you have
three tiers.
You keep that in mind and this should be validation data.
one more time
Hopefully this won't take more than a few minutes, but I'll just proceed with
the other lines of code.